المحادثات بين تحالف قوى الحريه والتغيير
والمجلس العسكري لم تهدء من غضب الشارع
السودانيه قبل ايامنا على توقيع اتفاق
الايطالي لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه خرج الالاف
في شمال الخرطوم يطالبون بتعليق المشنقه
لعبد الفتاح البرهان الذي قاد الانقلاب
العسكري رافعين شعارات تطالب بعوده
العسكري الى سكنات وبالعداله للضحيه
في الشارع
حتى نحقق
نخرج من اجله
الحوار مع المجلس العسكري الذي اطاح
بالكتله المدنيه الرئيسيه في البلاد مرفوض
بالنسبه للمحتاجين اما لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه
يجب اجراء انتخابات نزهه على حد تعبيرها
بالناضل كده لحد ما يحصل الحكم المدني
الحكم المدني الديمقراطي بيجيبوا
الانتخابات
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان بعبد الفتاح
البرهان وشخصيات المدنيه ودعاء الجميع الى
المشاركه في العمليه السياسيه في الوقت
الذي يتفاوض فيه التحالف مع الجيش للخروج
من الاسماء رشح جهات سودانيه فشل الاتفاق
في ظل اقصاء بعض الاطراف السياسيه
[موسيقى]